e aí galera hoje ovelha de hoje vai
começar assim é e não é
o dia quer gritar quando ele estava com
vontade de rir com esta casa porque eu
posso gritar michael jackson o pai de
diversa na minha vida 2 é bicho som de i
liga é tanto o nome do batom milhões não
estão com quem aqui pois é a galera
estou muito feliz porque eu estou muito
feliz de maio está feliz manto o padre
falar a verdade estou muito feliz estou
muito esplêndidas adeus em fotografar
terezinha trânsito e mesmo assim num
galera quem não sabe como eu tô agora
esse é o velho da felicidade porque
assim a gente vai embora
aí a gente fica assim meu deus meu deus
cadê aquele povo idiota tudo dias idiota
cadeia é muito bom e tive meus amigos
adianta que tem fim e porque assim deus
amigo deus amigo é a gente todo mundo é
amigo mas tem uns amigos que são idiotas
mandioca assim sbs fácil tia etecs amigo
quem partilhe dizia eu sou idiota mas é
um idiota do bem ea gente pode a gente
lembra toledo de jj que ninguém lembra
não agente lembrando base já sei que ele
já tocava fácil
além daquele jj está naquela assim
heitor conheço o braia cobra que libera
o brasil encontra aquele dia o idiota
agora quando é o idiota outro a pessoa
faz um plano da uva quente a
meu nome é fato que a possibilidade de
regular e sebrae a gente lembra na hora
para o banco da gente é amigo de ordem
porque pra falar a verdade o cara pode
puxar pando mas quando o cara volta 2 o
cara bota com a saudade que não tem
explicação
aí vai passar de castanheta meu deus
olha a amizade dos caras são tão bonita
que em seu que os carros são mostrados
na tv falando esmagando trocaram já um
amigo idiota é tipo copa é de quatro
patas mesmo assim pra você arranjar um
amigo bom e idiota o profissional
estiver chile chi doido cara tem que ser
muito [ __ ] ktt encontrar deus botas indo
no rumo ea gente encontrou uma mediana e
quando é pra encontrar um amigo na dieta
e não pode causar dano na cibele a top
china mesmo a tam é tinga não na
vermelho para jean vai tá eu acho que
todo mundo tem uma medida será ou não
essa gente meteu a mídia e mostrando
tentar esse vídeo é dedicada tantos
amigos idiotas imbecis doido mundo
merece ter cara melhor coisa você irá
com o seu amigo dele olha pra tia ele
tinha entender pra você de casa não vou
mostrar exclusivamente uma conversa eo e
chegou praticamente ontem uma conversa a
gente base eu cheguei com isso pelas a
falar sim aceito vecchi caó a forma que
a gente se comunica pra você não foi
nada fácil mas ganhou morte bem e só
forma quem se comunica o místico e caí
paulo o sonho já paulo
tem comida aí eu tô consumo e eu tomei a
minha vida acabou me ajudou a entender
melhor o que doeu não tem comida e um
poste na casa da minha sogra agora e
embora com medo mas só que é [ __ ]
entendido não continuar no cargo se teve
agora nesse momento porque nada sabe que
acaba sendo a comida lá é só uma hora da
cavalaria
pois é assim doida' ao colocar é amigo
de verdade quando o cara lindo esse não
é o seu amigo de verdade você chega pela
sefaz de ovi arma sexual ativa [ __ ]
ficou-me velhos ea que dá pra velhos ea
tudo que devia ter nem 781 góes taxa
para rodar um curta e é isso aí acaba o
vídeo de hoje eu quero que você pega
esse vídeo e mande por seu amigo dj pode
compartilhar esse viés e não do meu deus
não é cega
eu quero que você compartilhe esse vídeo
está no facebook sempre compartilhar
olha que vive legal para todos os amigos
j marca cheiro joão pedro josé cujo neto
otoni na marca no badoca liveiro marca
a marca completa padão marco léo santana
parangolé marca l ano e é isso aí
se você tem um amigo gostoso
se você tem um amigo idiota do bem você
vai dar um curtir aqui no facebook você
também vai dar aquele gostei desse
clicando gostei e me ajuda demais que eu
vou ficar muito feliz
cada vez que ele faz na equipe e em
outro vídeo no youtube em que pede
porque cansei de arata e então clique
não gostei eu quero você comente aqui
embaixo break 6
se tiver no facebook pode marcar a
pessoa também o nome do seu amigo dj do
bem pelo mj está assim tão de que a
mídia que eu quero que seja já é isso aí
muito obrigado a stx 58
obrigado a todos vocês fossem a 56 são
os meus amigos e de outros eu amo tanto
você e que um dia não encerrando na
praça portanto vamos fazer sexo